[Musique]
keane il était une heure de soleil manga
mangeant
c'est un matin ordinaire à la clinique
vétérinaire les assistantes près par les
patients pour le bloc opératoire
patrice l'un des sept vétérinaire de la
clinique examine mini tout juste amputé
d'une patte après un accident de chasse
faune se met toujours la place de
l'animal ont dit qu est ce que il nous
arrivait dans une situation pareille
donc je suppose que c'est terrible mais
l'animal le supporter relativement bien
donc assez régulièrement on essaie de
convaincre les gens de faire cette
chirurgie plutôt que de voir une
euthanasie l'animal pascal malvy
quasi normalement il faut le faire
comme tous ses confrères de la clinique
patrice est polyvalent une condition
nécessaire pour continuer à exercer son
métier avec passion
voilà
oui ça se passe très bien
on vient à ce métier là par vocation et
je suis pas capable de vous dire à quel
âge elle est venue cette vocation ç'a
toujours été donc peut-être six ans
étant peut-être avant je passe à rien
depuis toujours je voulais être
vétérinaire
quant à nos verres puis on va faire
[Musique]
après une séquence au bloc pour une
chirurgie des ovaires notre vétérinaire
retourne en consultation
façon vers 1h40 de température d'un
phénomène affectionnait
évidemment la vidéo viennent et
augmenter la vidéo bien c'est ce qui va
être responsable de sa jolie c'est pour
ça qu'il a la peau jaune
ce qui demain est un toxique simon
toxique pour les reins donc il faut le
mettre en perfusion pour essayer de les
évacuer le plus rapidement possible ses
pigments jungle le chat va devoir rester
plusieurs jours en soins intensifs
une dépense importante pour sa maîtresse
c'est extrêmement culpabilisant de se
dire bah je pourrais faire plus mais
financièrement je peux pas et on essaye
au maximum de
dédramatiser ça et puis de leur dire ben
on a tous des limites de toute façon et
on va faire au mieux avec les moyens
qu'on a c'est dur c'est dur
mais ça va j'espère que ça va aller
la relation avec le propriétaire c'est
un peu comme n'importe quelle relation
il ya une grosse partie de confiance
c'est
l'expérience c'est aussi l'empathie je
prends beaucoup à l'empathie si vous
n'avez pas cette empathie là ça passe
pas bien vous trouvez pas les mots tout
simplement où les mots utilisés sont pas
compris ou sont mal compris pendant que
patrice s'occupe des chiens et chats à
la clinique sébastien l'un de ses
collègues est appelée pour une vache en
souffrance
c'est lui qui est de garde pour la rural
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle les animaux
de la ferme qu'est ce qui se passe avec
la vache castille
elle est peu fatigué mais c'est le
comble habitude mais mais mais non on
pense que c'est trop d'accord c'est trop
donc elle avait l'air normal elle avait
le 12 décembre
l'éleveur un hollandais installé dans le
berry depuis sept ans est inquiet pour
cette vache laitière
elle respire vite comme ça depuis on
voit qu'elle respire un peu vite
d'accord elle a un rythme cardiaque très
très très fort
donc non non non le rythme cardiaque
fort fort comme ça toi tu as un problème
avec un corps étranger qui vient au
diaphragme et qui là et ils aperçurent
mais il ya une souffrance
on va lui mettre l'helmand et j'ai pris
de quoi les faire des injections après
15 minutes d'examen la décision est
prise sébastien va introduire un aimant
qui restera dans la panse de la vache à
l'aide d'un embout en plastique non
traumatisant pour l'animal
une pratique courante dans les élevages
bovins
camp
les gens qui entretiennent la route
passent trop près des champs et quand
ils entretiennent les bords de route
voilà si pour par malheur en entretenant
les bords de route ils détruisent une
partie du grillage du barbelé les vaches
peuvent à gérer les petits bouts de
barbelés d'accord et donc ces petits
bouts de barbelés c'est pas forcément
très gros mais ça vient dans l'estomac
de lavage dans la porte de la vache et
ça peut percer la poste de la vache et
donc on leur fait avaler des aimants
pour que ça puisse venir coller le corps
étranger à l'intérieur de la bande et il
corps étranger ne pas expulser mais il
reste au milieu
les vétérinaires de campagne font de
plus en plus de kilomètres pour visiter
des exploitations dont le nombre se
restreindre mais sébastien il voit au
moins un aspect positif emmènera
l'occasion ne s'est pas qu'on a une
mission dans tous les cas on est là pour
aider à ce que les éleveurs qui restent
dans la région puissent continuer à
bosser de manière correcte puisse
continuer à avoir accès aux soins etc
donc ça oui évidemment quand je sors
tous les jours je pense à 100
retour à la clinique l'état de jungle le
chat noir s'améliore la grande
difficulté du chat c'est que le chat
quand il est hospitalisé les très
souvent stressés blé chien aussi vous
allez me dire n'y vont pas l'exprimer de
la même manière le chat la tendance à se
tapir dans le fond de la cage et puis à
se replier un peu en boule ce qui fait
que la perfusion et des difficile à
faire passer mais en général ils
tolèrent relativement bien les les
perfusions
et on est c'est même plutôt un signe
c'est à dire que quand ils commencent à
bouger dans la cage s'agite etc c'est
que déjà ça va mieux donc qu'il nous
tarde qu'il arrache à perte est-ce pas
allez petite injection
c'est stéphanie une des assistantes qui
se charge de surveiller les animaux
hospitalisé c'est de la surveillance sur
toute la journée du matin jusqu'au soir
et puis le mal le lendemain matin on
recommence et on vérifie s'il ya décès
si elles des urines 6 et du vomi si l'on
mangé si la perf à coude et toute la
nuit c'est comme une infirmière dans
soit dans un bloc opératoire ou une
infirmière qui fait des soins avec un
docteur c'est comme ça toute la journée
dans la salle d'attenté un couple de
fidèles clients avec leurs yorkshire
attendent pour une visite de routine
docteur pic pic c'est patrice le
monsieur piqûre de la famille alors
valoir son carnet de santé
monsieur et madame possède quatre chiens
tous des yorkshire la bombe du bonheur
pour moi c'est plus gentil que les gens
aiment beaucoup
une expression j'aime pas que les gens
que les gens utilisent beaucoup il nous
parle souvent de beta chagrin j'aime pas
cette expression là parce que
effectivement la vie se termine toujours
par un chagrin mais c'est quand même
beaucoup de moments de bonheur c'est
cela qu'il faut se rappeler allez c'est
parti
on est fusionnelle avec nos animaux
évidemment y en a deux sur les quatre
condamnés y en a deux qui sont plus
proches de mon épouse c'est eux qui
seront plus proches de moi c'est comme
ça un chien animal
l'animal est entrée dans la famille
c'est très clair donc la charge
affective oui elle est juste les normes
quoi c'est sûr mais ça peut être un
chien se veut être un chat ça peut être
cauchon donne une gerbille une poule des
poules de compagnie ça peut être des
animaux auxquels on
a tâché - d'affection il ya quelques
années de ça
à l'autre bout de la clinique sébastien
vient d'être appelé pour une urgence
on part sur un sur un village sur une
vache donc une mise bas de vaches et
donc c'est une vache qu'ils veulent pour
la première fois
le mans à l'aris pas intervenir tout
seul donc on va essayer on va aller les
des points pour lui permettre de faire
son premier petit veau
[Musique]
perrine le placenta de la jeune vache
s'est déclenchée prématurément et son
petit veau n'est plus alimentée en
oxygène en gros ceci pour sexy le petit
mot et puis vascularisé malheureusement
il pourra
montrer droit
mais grâce aux efforts du vétérinaire et
de l'éleveur le nouveau né est sauvé in
extremis
[Musique]
et on a un petit garçon
tellement il est possible qu'il ait un
peu manqué d'oxygène s'est pour sa part
au moins la tête par en arrière c'est
des petits symptômes d'hypoxie coin
c'est le manque d'oxygène qui peuvent
générer ce genre de choses vous bien
fait un certain nombre d'injections
justement pour stimuler l'oxygénation
cérébrale là c'est parce que j'ai dû
faire comme un commencé comme vous en
avez dû candidate peut-être encore je
vous laisse faire un tour ailleurs faire
s'asseoir chose
pour l'éleveur qui possède 120 bêtes en
races à viande bio la préservation du
cheptel est une question de survie
on subit la baisse des prix de la viande
donc si en plus on perd on perd deux
places
et c'est pas bon du tout
donner satisfaction à moyen long terme
puis celle ci c'est tous les jours quand
ça se passe bien on a notre petit moment
de bonheur dans la jambe il faut aimer
ça pour continuer ce métier là c'est sûr
parce que c'est vrai que les gens qui le
supporte mal c'est resterai sein de deux
manières je sais que quand on vit sa
plus comme un stress mais comme quelque
chose qui va donner un petit peu
d'énergie bien c'est vrai que c'est pas
possible de pouvoir faire ce métier
celle
qu'on avait l'ensemble notamment
si les écoles vétérinaires font toujours
le plein de moins en moins de jeunes
diplômés accepte de soigner les animaux
de production une situation qui inquiète
les éleveurs aujourd'hui les
vétérinaires c'est comme un désert
médical et des régions vous faut une
heure et demie avant d'avoir premier
vétérinaire
voilà donc sans eux
sans eux on ne pourrait pas mettre à
voir des vaches allaitantes et faire la
mise bas alors
jungle donc il a mangé cette nuit à la
clinique les choses ont l'air de
s'arranger pour le petit chat noir il
est plus rose et qu'avant et puis les
plus vifs le voyez
il a retrouvé un petit peu de forme et
je pense qu'on va envisager une sortie
cet après midi je vais voir avec la
maîtresse si aujourd'hui l'engouement
pour les métiers liés aux animaux est
très fort chez les jeunes générations
ils sont aussi nombreux à déchanter
après quelques années de pratique voilà
bon petit chat qui va rentrer chez lui
ils ont fait beaucoup de sacrifices pour
à réfléchir leur formation leur
intégration dans les écoles arrivé au
terme des études et au bout du compte
ils se rendent compte que la gestion de
l'eau chanson d'en parler allait
compliquer la relation avec les gens pas
si simple que ça il faut effectivement
du temps et il ya beaucoup de gens qui
se découragent donc ces gens là j'ai
envie de leur dire venez venez avec nous
mais voir le métier il faut voir toutes
les facettes pour voir que les écoutez
positif voir les larmes il faut voir les
décès il faut voir aussi sens parce que
malheureusement ça fait partie du métier
les vétérinaires sont les premiers
témoins de l'évolution de nos rapports
avec les animaux des animaux de plus en
plus proche si bien qu'on ne fait plus
vraiment la part entre ce qu'ils sont
réellement et les multiples fantasme que
nous projetons sur eux
[Musique]